so we are cutting to the chase where the  95 meets the 215 northern beltway  come on along we're going  centennial bowling  you know maybe i've gotten too far into  the weeds and trying to explain all the  stuff that's going on in the final phase  of the project viewer greg writes in  with a very simple question what year  will the centennial bowl be done i'm  pretty sure it's been mentioned here  before but  when we've all got so much going on just  trying to get through every day you  might be looking for a number to wrap  your brain around remember the big  shocker from a couple of weeks ago  when we talked about how oso block is  going to be shutting down for three  years between deer springs and the 215  so do the math  the nevada department of transportation  says it's all supposed to be wrapped up  in 2024. we'll be keeping you updated  buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone  if there's something driving you crazy  email me traffic eight eight news now  dot com